Keir us caris cross Kursk carrots Karis
what is Karras and how can you use it to
get started creating your own machine
learning models stay tuned to find out
welcome to cloud AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning
my name is yu Fang Guo and on this
episode of AI adventures I'll show you
how to get started with Kerris in the
quickest way possible it's never been
easier to get started with Karis not
only is Karis built into tensorflow via
tensorflow da Kara's you also don't even
have to install or configure anything if
you use a tour like Kaggle kernels all
you need to do is create your kaggle
account if you need it and sign in then
you have access to all that Karis has to
offer
caris also exists as a standalone
library but the test flow version has
the exact same api's and some extra
features let's start over to my kago
kernel where i'll show you how to get
started using Karis right now in a
previous episode we did some machine
learning on the data set fashion em nest
it's a data set of 10 different types of
fashionable items from pants and shirts
to shoes and handbags all presented in
28 by 28 pixel grayscale mmm grayscale
today we'll do a similar analysis using
terrace so to use Karis we're just
import test flow like usual these
imports are actually identical to what
we had before and we'll pull in numpy
and pandas and matplotlib just as we
normally would
and we continue operating kind of in the
usual way we'll pull in our training and
test CSVs and load them up in pandas and
take a look at what they look like we
got our label column on the far left
with numbers from 0 through 9 and we
have our pixels pixel 1 2 3 all the way
up to pixel 700 and
eighty-four I've got a function here to
pre-process our data a little bit it's
similar to what we had before I've just
cleaned it up and made it a little more
concise I'm pulling out the features and
dividing by 255 so we normalize all the
grayscale values to be between 0 and 1
and I'll pull out the labels as well and
have them both be represented as an
umpire arrays will use that function to
pull out our train and test data from
the data frame and associate them to
explicit variables train features and
train labels test features and test
labels and we can see that the final
shape of these variables are exactly as
we would expect 60,000 or examples with
784 columns and then our labels are just
our 60,000 values and we can take a peek
at one of them this is our 20th training
feature set and some pixels in the
middle we can see that there indeed
values between 0 and 1 and we can also
visualize it here we have a shirt and we
can see that it looks exactly as you
would expect kind of grand grainy and
grayscale now with Kerris in this
particular case we're gonna need two one
hot and code our data and what that
means is we're going to take our
training labels which used to be just
values like 0 3 7 and turn them into
each of them into an array of length 10
all 10 values in the array will be zeros
except for one value that one value will
be a 1 and so that's why it's called one
hot encoding now where is that one
located it's going to be exactly the
number that it came from so for example
if the value was 7 the 7th 0 will be a 1
if the number was 4 then the 4th 0 will
be a 1 hence one hot encoding so we'll
run Karis dye utils that to categorical
which is a handy utility function that
will just do this for us and we'll
observe that the train labels have now
turned from 60,000 rows of numbers to
60,000 rows with 10 columns and we can
see that indeed that same example
label that we saw before now the zeroeth
index has a 1 and everything else
remains a zero and now comes the really
fun part of working with Karis creating
our model Karis supplies a really easy
and intuitive way to build up your model
from the ground up in this case we're
going to make a sequential model and add
layers on top of it
the first layer will have is has 30
notes and has an activation function of
a rectified linear unit or raloo which
in the case of tensor flow that we used
before was the default activation
function then we'll have a nother fully
connected layer or dense layer with 20
new orleans this time also with a
rayleigh function and finally we'll do
our final mapping to the 10 output
values of 0 through 9 and have an
activation of the softmax which
basically just distributes our
probabilities across the 10 kind of
buckets and now we're ready to compile
our model caris uses this notation of
compiling a model as similar to when you
do something like a string builder or
something to just say I'm done put it
all together for me and we also apply a
loss optimizer and metrics for what kind
of values we want to get out of it for
what how to optimize for the best values
as well as how we want to measure loss
in this case we're using categorical
cross entropy because our outputs are
categorical and cross entropy in this
case happens to be a nice way to measure
our loss or error with our model created
we're ready to run training training
with Karis is as easy as calling dot fit
when we called that fit all we need to
supply are the training features and
training labels it's also a good idea to
supply epics and batch size so we can
control the training a little more in
this case we have supply that a pack of
two which means we'll go through the
entire data set twice over and we'll
supply a batch size of 128 this means
with that with each training step the
model will see 128 examples which
help guide it and to adjust its
parameters and so we can see here Karis
has some really useful outputs as the
training happens and it gives us a sense
of the progress it also then prints out
the bloss and accuracy at the end of
each epoch but seeing the accuracy at
the end loss at the end of training
isn't nearly as useful as evaluation we
need to see the accuracy against our
actual test dataset so let's call our
model evaluate function and this time
pass in our test features and test
labels this will give us an accuracy and
we can print that out and take a look
that we can see we got eighty four point
seven percent accuracy and of course we
could certainly do better than that
with increased ad hocs a more
sophisticated model and other approaches
but this is just an intro to Karis and
hopefully this will give you a good
starting point to start playing around
Karis and seeing all that Karis can do
Karis has an amazing community and lots
of samples which when you combine with
Kalos community gives you a truly epic
set of resources to get started the
right way thanks for watching this
episode of cloud AI adventures and if
you enjoyed it please like it and be
sure to subscribe to get all the latest
episodes right when they come out now
what are you waiting for head on over to
cattle and start playing around with
Karis today